first let's go away way back in time the
day-to-day life of our distant ancestors
was based on one thing survival and to
survive is to hunt so with food we will
begin our story
let's imagine two hunters preparing the
catch of the day eating in groups
requires them to intuitively agree on
what defines a fair share a fair share
requires a split into equal sized pieces
an unfair share occurs when someone
obtains a larger piece at someone else's
expense the idea of fair versus unfair
is the basis of divisibility remember if
we say some quantity is divisible by
four then it implies that we can form
four equal sized pieces now in order to
hunt successfully our ancestors needed a
way to predict animal migration patterns
and plan future hunts how could they
predict the most successful times to
hunt this question leads to one of the
oldest and most powerful human
technologies the clock all clocks are
based on some repetitive pattern which
divides the flow of time into segments
to find repetitive patterns they look
towards the heavens
the most obvious cycle is the rising and
the falling of the Sun each day
however they would have required longer
cycles to track longer periods of time
they look to the moon which seemed to
gradually grow and shrink over many days
and every so often a beautiful event
would occur a full moon but was superior
between men full moon to the next
constant to answer this they needed a
method of counting ancient artifacts
show they counted this pattern using
notches or numerals each numeral would
represent one unit such as one day
grouping these units together allowed
them to build numbers numbers allowed
our ancestors to calculate exactly 29
days between each full moon this is the
origin of a month however when they try
to divide 29 into equal parts they ran
into a problem it was impossible no
matter how hard you try you cannot split
29 into equal pieces
we could say the 29 is unbreakable
unbreakable numbers are known as prime
numbers imagine that our hunter was
mathematically curious as he continued
his day he couldn't stop thinking about
these prime numbers how many other
numbers are prime how big did they get
first he tried dividing all numbers into
two categories he lists prime numbers on
the left and other numbers on the right
the first thing a mathematician would do
is look for patterns at first they seem
to dance back and forth in a strange
pattern he was on to something now let's
do a modern trip to see the bigger
picture
the trick is to use a spiral first we
list all possible numbers in a growing
spiral then we color all the prime
numbers blue
finally we zoom out to see millions of
numbers here is one of the great
examples of true mathematical beauty
this is a pattern of primes which goes
on and on forever incredibly the
structure of this pattern is still
unsolved today this idea was finally
advanced sometime around 300 BC in
ancient Greece with a philosopher known
as Euclid of Alexandria Euclid
understood that all numbers split into
two distinct categories prime numbers
which we cannot share equally and
composite numbers which we can he begins
by realizing than any number can be
divided down until you reach a group of
smallest equal numbers and by definition
these smallest numbers are always prime
numbers hmm to be clear imagine the
universe of all possible numbers and
ignore the primes now pick any composite
number and break it down you are always
left with prime numbers
Euclid knew that every number could be
expressed using a group of smaller
primes or building blocks no matter what
number you choose it can always be built
with addition of smaller Prime's this is
the root of his discovery known as the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic as
follows take any number say 30 and find
all the prime numbers it divides into
equally this is known as factorization
this will give us the prime factors in
this case 2 3 & 5 are the prime factors
of 30 you could realize that you could
then multiply these prime factors a
specific number of times to build the
original number in this case you simply
multiply each factor once to build 30
two times three times five can be
thought of as a special key or
combination for 30 so every possible
number has one and only one prime
factorization a good analogy is to
imagine each number as a different lock
the unique key for each lock would be
its prime factorization no 2 lakh share
a key no two numbers share a prime
factorization this idea marks one of the
greatest advances in the history of
mathematics and will return thousands of
years later in our story